Magnus first of all welcome back to the
grandchester always a pleasure to have
you around this is the first official
games after abdicating title give us
your initial feelings
um after the first few moves yeah I
haven't really uh
uh you know played or studied just first
recently so it was kind of showing
um but at least I set it the ship like a
little bit in the last couple of rounds
so uh it's not a it's not a disaster but
yeah overall uh overall was really rusty
and we started with the Polish in Poland
how did you come to that that idea yeah
it was something actually uh Peter
suggested a couple days ago and I was
like yeah sure
um so when you make such an opening
choice that obviously increases the
variance quite a bit
um and uh
I don't think like
against an unprepared opponent I don't
think it's that bad but unfortunately I
didn't
yeah I didn't remember what I was
supposed to do and then my position was
pretty bad early on like I suspect
probably after that I had some chances
to uh to come back a little bit but it
was always difficult and he did he
deserved to win but um
yeah uh polish and bowling didn't didn't
work definitely not the star that you
envisioned but in the second game it
felt like vintage Magnus you were
pressing him in uh the late middle game
did you feel like you had any chances at
any point well first of all I thought I
was better from the opening and then
um like five minutes later I was
struggling to take away so I don't think
it was it was vintage but yeah I did
feel like I was trying to I was starting
to play well at some point also from a
psychological point of view starting to
put a bit of pressure then at some point
he found a very critical move there
Quincy eighth and after that I sort of
have to after exchange queens and then
it looks like could be promising for
white still but it probably probably
wasn't but it's it's typical typical
Wesley
um that he
um he usually defends pretty well when
he's
um
when he's up against it and we know that
you are a man that generally likes to do
some physical workouts before your games
you go skiing occasionally I saw you
posted uh a soccer photo with Christian
pulisic was that from today or
no no that was from from London uh last
last week that's good too and good to
know okay Magnus uh go get your rest
we'll see you tomorrow thank you